You know,
what we like to do as,
um,
as a society is,
uh,
is,
is put things in boxes and label things
and um,
you know,
we'd like to be able to say this is an
elephant and this is a zebra.
And it was very easy to do that with,
uh,
with blogs and journalism.
Uh,
it was easier than it is now,
uh,
even a couple of years ago.
So bloggers operated a certain way.
They wanted to be treated a certain way.
They had an expectation level,
there was a,
there was an ethos of,
of transparency and ethos of,
uh,
you know,
doing things that you do and you don't
do it with bloggers.
That was kind of an unwritten rule that
was published.
And,
but what we've seen over the last couple
of years though is that the elephants
and zebras have made it.
And I don't know what's,
what anymore.
So we have a,
we have journalists that blog all the
time and I'm on twitter.
Um,
and yet we still have to treat them like
professional journalists and is
absolutely.
And,
and as a way of operating with them,
there are bloggers that basically one
little media companies and we have to,
they expect to be treated a certain way
but not quite the same way that the,
uh,
the times once,
um,
but with different kinds of rules of the
road.
And then we have individuals that maybe
have no rules whatsoever.
They just individuals who had day jobs
who are publishing for passion.
So it's very blurry.
And,
um,
and so the rules of engagement really a
variant and the blending of what's a
journalist and what's a blogger is,
you know,
is obliterate.
I mean,
uh,
I mean it's more clear if you work for a
major media organization that you're a
journalist and that's,
that's pretty clear cut,
but,
you know,
let's take us out like tech crunch,
uh,
which is,
one of the most popular blogs on the
web,
which is independent,
you know,
is that a media company?
Do we treat them like we do?
Journalists don't know.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an or talking points.
Now here's another example.
So I think that,
I think at each individual is going to
develop their own rules of engagement.
Each company will develop their own
rules of engagement and some of those
will be written in,
some of those will be unwritten and
we'll have to test them in an ethical
way and see and we'll see what works and
what doesn't.
I mean,
I'll give you an example with blogging.
Um,
you know,
a blogging as a,
as a company and not with people or uh,
or fake blogs,
uh,
never went anywhere.
It was something that was a,
that was kind of a nonstarter on
twitter.
It's,
this seems to be more receptivity
towards that kind of stuff.
Um,
I don't know if there's effective,
but there seems to be some more
acceptance there.
So every community,
every site seems every person who seems
to have their own rules and it's,
it's extraordinarily messy and it's not
easy to just box things up.
So I joined Edelman in 2006 and I
started my blog in,
in 2004.
And,
uh,
when I was the first two years I was
blogging,
I was in a small PR company with 30
people,
so we had,
you know,
15 clients and,
that gave me a canvas that was huge.
I could write a anything,
anybody not be concerned about it
because,
uh,
I didn't really have to worry about
getting tripped up when I went to
edelman.
Um,
you know,
that's a client that's an organization
with 3,500
people around the world and,
you know,
we have thousands of clients and I don't
even know who our clients are.
I mean,
it's just so it's just huge.
And,
you know,
we could represent one company in,
in,
uh,
in one market and not represent them
anywhere else.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
so it's really,
it's a,
it's a very huge organization.
And um,
you know,
the wakeup call I got was,
uh,
about two years ago,
I,
um,
initially when I got on twitter,
actually I'm in a stream of
consciousness.
I just began to write about my media
habits.
And,
uh,
and one of the things that I,
at the time,
I was getting a complimentary
subscription to the print edition of Pc
magazine and,
uh,
and so what I ended up writing was I get
a copy of Pc magazine for free,
but I throw it away.
Now,
the reason I said I said that is because
I actually was reading it online at the
time.
Well,
I'm somebody who doesn't like us,
uh,
and doesn't like Edelman,
um,
reached out to the editor of PC magazine
at the time and,
you know,
he was understandably upset about it
and,
uh,
and he wrote a,
a pretty nasty,
uh,
op-ed.
I'm criticizing not just a me but
basically threatening to black list our
entire pr firm.
So,
uh,
so he was basically saying he was
posturing,
that he would,
you know,
any,
any approach from our,
from a to him or his editors would just
be a nonstarter because of this little
tweet that I wrote.
And that was a huge wakeup call.
I had a,
I had to go on my blog and a and a and
ride a,
a,
an apology,
I mean,
it wasn't like somebody twisted my arm.
I was real already to do that.
I had no intention of slamming it.
It was just a,
it was just something I wrote in the
stream of consciousness and in twitter
didn't give me a lot of room in it and
it was early,
early days for twitter.
Uh,
but that,
that was a sign to me that I can't do
what I was doing before.
It's,
I don't have that level of freedom and
it's not because somebody's watching
over me,
but it's because I just,
you know,
I have to,
I have to protect the firm.
I've got to protect our clients and
obviously as part of that I got of
protect me.
And uh,
and so that was,
uh,
that was,
a,
a pretty bad experience then,
uh,
but,
you know,
I came out for the better for it.
And I think so to de Soto.